the u.s consumer product safety
commission says now is a great time
to take a cpr refresher course its
latest data shows an increase in child
drownings of children under the age of
15
from 2016 to 2018. drownings are
preventable and the pandemic forcing
closures prevented many families from
signing their kids up for swim lessons
nikki fleming says kids should get
refresher swimming lessons
parents of course refresh your cpr
courses
as well as making sure you have plenty
of safety barriers
at your home or whatever pool you plan
to attend
the key to prevention is multiple layers
of protection not just
one so a four-sided four-foot fence
with a self-closing self-latching gate
in addition you want to also have a pull
alarm
a door alarm even a pool cover any
additional physical berries between your
child
and the water and always have a
designated
water watcher for your children if
you're hosting a party even hire a
lifeguard from a local ymca or community
center